pongé claude malhuret bonsoir est-ce
qu'on doit appeler ministre les droits
de l'homme ou secrétaire comme on veut
c'est quoi serait-il si après tu y étais
un peu long c'est secrétaire d'état
auprès du premier ministre chargé les
droits du musée de l'homme se tenir
droite peuvent très bien florence
belkacem bonsoir yannick noah râble
quand on est ravi soit parce qu'ils ont
peiné à gagner quand même bien je
gagnais mais j'ai encore eu des
problèmes physiques j'ai fini pas jour
il ne faut pas croire samassa my permis
dans le désarroi total
ce que je veux dire j'ai eu des crampes
aux niveau de l'estomac et à nice est
descendu en bas et puis bon c'est pas
évident je veux dire bon parce que je
suis beaucoup trop balèze gédémus qu'ils
france beaucoup trop vite
bon c'est vrai que je mesure 1 mètre 90
89 kg bons matches on est comme ça je
suis née gro ça t'arrive à dire c'est
que mon jeu suite à un problème physique
je suis là pour parler de raciste parce
que bon jeu c'est vrai que je suis pas
noir je suis pas blanc non plus enfin je
suis pas très clair c'est vrai mais ce
que je veux dire à la recherche d'une
identité et bonche content de parler
racisme à tenir si enrayer qu'un georges
wolinski
en soirée les jeunes urbains où ça ici
étaient déjà venus allonger
c'est la première fois tu as dis à ta
femme de dd l'a alors que maryse est au
courant maryse est au courant et c'est
surtout elle ça ma fille qui m'a dit oh
quelle chance tu avoues mais vient avec
l'âge la prochaine fois prochaine fois
je la mènerai philippe guérin bonsoir
alors claude malhuret on va commencer
par toi est ce que j'ai lu dans un
journal que tu as été baba et que
j'avais les cheveux longs sur les
épaules c'est vrai quand j'en avais
quand on allait et maintenant tu gardes
que les moustaches un souvenir des
années 60 les cheveux j'aurais du mal à
les garder mais de toute façon dans les
années 70 je crois que j'étais pas le
seul à être baba avoir des cheveux la
maman on était beaucoup serré la main et
a fait et les moustaches c'est comme un
souvenir les années 70 oui parce qu'à
l'époque j'avais les moustaches et la
barbe depuis j'ai rasé la barre mais par
contre golinski lui tu as vu il sait se
pousser la barbe
ça fait un an et demi et alors tu en es
content oui parce qu'avant la télé je
trouvais j'avais peut-être comme un
ballon de recrues alors ça casse un
petit peu le rythme
ça donne un genre c'est vrai voilà où
est ce que tu as pu sur la tête tu là
aujourd'hui c'est ma dernière chance
d'avoir un genre ou à la maintenance et
un grand show deux itinéraires qui se
croisent pour en parler tout à l'heure
oui alors claude tu es docteur vraiment
tué huit mètres ça en quoi et bien
médecine tropicale et puis et biologie
médecine légale a passé beaucoup de
temps dans le tiers-monde une dizaine
d'années avec médecins sans frontières
mais quand on est spécialisée en
médecine tropicale c'est une spécialité
difficile à exercer ici alors évidemment
je l'exercé ailleurs ouais mais si
quelqu'un s'évanouissent est là parmi
nous tu serais si yannick avait un
malaise pas jean doussain capable je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il vaudrait
peut-être mieux prendre le téléphone et
appeler sos à bord il a perdu la série
personnes quelques années quelques
années les jeux que chez sos pénis a
perdu la main probablement oui on perd
vite la main dans ce métier si on arrête
et ça fait quand même quelques années
que j'ai pas fait de maître ça moi
monsieur mini moi je vais pas vous poser
de questions sur le pen mais par contre
je devrais vous demander une chose
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'étiez pas là
la fameuse nuit chaude l'assemblée
nationale où le groupe du front national
a pris un peu en charge l'assemblée
parce que ça a été fantastique pour vous
vous seriez reçu une baffe pas parce que
par rapport à la députée rpr qui était
fait bousculer sur le feu effectivement
mais je n'y étais pas parce que tout
s'est passé un petit peu par surprise
dans la soirée d'ailleurs la soirée
s'est calmée au milieu puis ça remue
rennes va démarrer au milieu de la nuit
il y avait un seul ministre présentait
albin chalandon quelques députés la
plupart étaient retournés comme ils le
font tous les week-ends dans leur
circonscription et le front national a
d'ailleurs savez c'était au toit et moi
j'étais chez moi je crois que ce soir là
c'est pas aller bosser mais je ne suis
pas la radio heure par heure pour savoir
ce qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
et si le front national a décidé de
lancer une guérilla il avait décidé de
le faire justement parce qu'il savait
c'était moment où il y avait le moindre
truc tu connais ce bouquin je viens de
le extraordinaire alors ça c'est alors
wolinski bon le connaît mais jérôme
duhamel est ce que c'est le le troisième
frère duhamel du tout parce que je
n'arrive qu'une fois chirac a dit j'ai
fait un cauchemar
j'ai rêvé que tu avais trois duhamel en
fait mon ennui c'est n'osais pas le
troisième mais non c'est le petit fusil
la deuxième aile l'écrivain qui on a
complètement oublié jamais d'accord
c'est à dire que mal on connaît alain
coquelle et patrice en connaît on
connaît plus l'écrivain
on se dit toujours joué mais lui c'est
le fils de georges duhamel deux petits
fils le petit fils au lit les appeler
plusieurs livres l'idée du livre c'est
absolument génial c'est que donc c'est
tout les pourcentages ça va 2 1% à 100%
alors lui pivot il met des signes et
nous on n'est pas en ouvre au hasard 68%
des français sont favorables au père
noël par exemple qui a des choses
complètement son affidé 18% des français
pour la sieste le dimanche voilà on est
si quand on les prend absolument gérer
ensemble quand on les lit les unes après
les autres que ça devient drôle ouais
moi qu'il faut tout lire faut l'acheter
pour picorer folie qu il ya un truc et
il ya un truc est très étonnant là
dedans c'est qu'on dit après à valérie
et charlie hebdo wolinski dessine
notamment pour libération et le nouvel
observateur et un couvre il ya un trou
alors il faut qu'on en parle
ce dont je suis désolé si tu vas nous
expliquer pourquoi tu parles pas de
l'humanité ah non c'est pas moi je sais
pas pourquoi ils ont pas dit pourquoi
moi ce sont des années qui ont été très
heureuse
alors là je vais prendre mes petites
notes parce que j'ai retrouvé les choses
que tu as dis quand même à l'époque où
tu étais à lui mais lille et je suis
désolé de faire ça je m'élance et
palaiseau les inventeurs que je t'adore
oui c'est pour choquer mais lurex ou
alors tu as dit le goulag est ce
vraiment important
je te demande pas de répondre à chaque
fois sur le tu peux répondre en bloc à
la fin tu as dit l'urss un pays qui
tente une expérience le goût là il est
vraiment important ça m'étonnerait que
je dirais écoute c c'était
malheureusement dans l'urss un pays qui
tente une également important
actuellement 1000 l'afghanistan je
déplore mais je ne condamne pas j'ai dit
des choses pour que les les gîtes s'ils
ne sont pas contents en urss ils peuvent
partir ben moi je pense qu'il devrait du
coup dehors d'accord cuba ce pays
respire l' envie de s'amuser c'est vrai
oui
non mais je sais pas moi je te dise qu
un an mais c'est vrai j'y suis heureux
que ça tu trouves pas terrible qui
disent des trucs comme ça parce qu'on
l'a d'or en plus voler ce qui nous fait
marrer on va parler tout à l'heure c'est
ces trois nouveaux bus de nouveaux
bouquins de bandes dessinées qui sont
qu'ils sont géniaux mais alors enfin je
continue dans l'huma le seul journal au
net
à l'époque je dis ça au but c'est de la
provocation ouais mais c'est ça que je
veux demander alors c'est un désir
d'être diabolisés comme ça devenir
aragon devenir patrick besson ça je
pense par marc mais ça m'agace et parce
que il ya des tabous contre eux
voyez les choses qu'on n'a pas le droit
de dire là on n'avait pas le droit de
dire à l'époque où moi je suis à dix ans
c'est s'est fait un article dans
lesquels je ne disais pas c'est un
paradis mais je disais que c'était pas
non plus un enfer et à l'époque c'était
un tabou il fallait absolument dire que
l'urss était un enfer or maintenant
c'est génial magre ans déjà il ya eu des
articles aussi bien dans le figaro qu
ailleurs on disait que quand même moi il
y avait une vie qui était vrai pour
certains côtés peut-être plus
intéressante que celle qu'on peut avoir
la nuit ouais tu préfères l'urss aux
etats-unis mènent maintenant c'est vrai
je ne connais pas je ne connais pas les
états unis mais il est certain que j'ai
je serais plus inquiet dans les rues de
new york dans les rues de moscou
ouais ça dépend si on s'était dit c'est
dans la rue l'univ dans les rues de la
havane aussi je crois l on peut se
promener tranquillement dans les rues de
la havane
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
villes d'amérique du sud ont changé
parce que tu m'as dit tout à l'heure que
je faisais plus d'interviews juste et me
dis moi pourquoi tu as dis ça au fond
sérieusement pourquoi tu as fait toutes
ces déclarations à l'époque parce que je
le pensais et tu le pense toujours
je vais te citer georges pompidou ouais
j'aime pas les gaullistes ils ont
beaucoup donné dans le procès vietti
j'ai pas le temps de mentir ouais
est ce que je fais trop de choses vraies
et en 25 ans si j'étais menteur si je
n'ai pas sincère et si je disais
finalement des choses tellement ignoble
je crois que
je détesterais plus parce qu'on me
détestent contador je te les donnerait
trois fois donc on les gens font la part
des choses pour faire la part de la
provocation
et puis aussi la sincérité et puis aussi
de la vérité parce que c'est moi c'était
salutaire de faire ça à l'époque
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut
parfois dire des choses que j'ai été
invité à l'ambassade de à cuba ouais et
les diplomates qui étaient là nous
disait je me disais on fait des rapports
dans lequel sur la situation à cuba dans
lesquels on dit que c'est finalement pas
si mal ouais et ses rapports sont
censurés à paris de ce qu'on nous dit
faut pas dire ça
mouais qu'est ce qu'on pense mal une
étoile moi j'ai dû opérer au psg dès
maintenant parce que c'était occident
c'est ce que j'allais dire j'essaie de
relativiser les choses parce qu'il ya
quinze ans je me mettais dans les rues
en train de manifester et dire vietnam
laos cambodge vaincrons j'ai participé à
ce qui est lancé aujourd'hui
depuis je suis à la frontière du
cambodge en ethiopie en afghanistan et
là il est certain que la vierge est
d'accord du tout d'accord et pas du tout
d'accord avec ce que je disais donc je
suis modeste et pas du tout d'abord est
ce que dit aujourd'hui
wolinski cela dit il est normal de ne
pas être d'accord ou à cuba ou en urss
georges wolinski dessinateur célèbre
effectivement peut se promener sans
aucun problème mais cuba est le pays du
monde où il ya le plus de prisonniers
politiques en maintenant on va parler de
deux autres livres de wolinski sont
aussi bien d'ailleurs cédé dessin il
s'appelle gaston l'habite et autres qui
s'appelle bonne année ils sortent tous
les ans même temps responsable qui est
sortie depuis trois mois
ouais je dois dire que le premier en
parler avant un repas quand même y'a
encore quelques
réticences pourtant la vivre d'une
grande santé moi je trouve ça drôle mais
depuis je ne pense qu'à ça je trouve que
tu tiens une ligne